that's the most uncomfortable you can
get the man appointed as a stopgap now
in charge of the biggest brand in
football all againist Sasha was never
supposed to be the permanent manager of
Manchester United at least not this soon
but he has turned around fortunate Old
Trafford the extent that his appointment
became inevitable you know when people
get a new job and I say is the dream job
they've had and they've always dreamt
about or played for that club or managed
this club that's more true to any to me
you don't do anyone optimism was limited
when salsa was appointed caretaker
manager last December now on the brink
of the top four finish and in a
Champions League quarter-final
approaching not bad for a man whose only
previous managerial success came at
Norwegian club Mulder but he vowed not
to get carried away I'm just going to be
myself as I've always been
I know salsa is expected to be paid
around seven million pounds a year by
United less than half his predecessor
Jose Jose Mourinho but he certainly
preferred by the big-name players here
the first day when you arrived it just
told us to enjoy playing football again
because when you're doing when you don't
enjoy playing football
there's no point playing just get back
to the basics and enjoy as a player at
salsa was loved by fans bought those
glory days had started to feel like a
distant memory for so long Manchester
United's success was taken for granted
in each of the first 22 seasons of the
Premier League they finished third or
higher but with Sir Alex Ferguson's
departure came decline and only time
will tell if Oleg and our salsa can
bring stability back to the club he may
not have at the pedigree of other
managers but salsa makes business sense
Manchester United shares have risen by
around 30% since the day he was given
the temporary role clearly there is an
obvious attraction in managers like
Mourinho and Zidane and others but there
has to be some degree of cultural
alignment and I think really that's
that's what the social appointment is
all about
the fans even have their own song for
the 46 year old he has brought a smile
back to this part of Manchester I think
it's also really embodies what clubs
about and yeah I'm prepared to wait for
him see to get it right best thing they
ever could have done he's gonna win the
treble honestly let's wait and see we've
already sacked three managers with Olay
at the wheel permanently the mood is
buoyant but the states have just gone up
for all involved Martha Kellner Sky News
Manchester